[Music]
the urgency of the coronavirus pandemic
has seen an unprecedented surge in
scientific innovation
one breakthrough originates right
beneath us
wastewater tells an intriguing tale of a
city
and the movement of a virus in all its
mutations
an early warning system but strangely
one that some governments are turning
their noses up at
well it does stink no one wants to talk
about it or go anywhere near it but
monitoring waste water for traces of a
pathogen
can provide a detailed picture of an
entire community
without the biases and limitations of
regular testing methods
this sewage treatment plant in frankfurt
may not look very exciting
but there's a lot more to waste water
than meets the eye
professor susanna lachner analyzes it to
detect the presence of the novel
coronavirus
the wastewater can also give us
information about which mutations are to
be found in which catchment areas
the environmental scientist and her team
at the technical university of darmstadt
have developed a method to monitor how
much virus is circulating in a
particular area
and to identify which strains are
present to see if say
the brazilian or british ones are
spreading
the method has met with considerable
interest in other countries
as we see it the method is ready for use
and it is in fact
already being used in the netherlands
the united states and spain
in cooperation with their health
authorities
it's not being used in germany even
though it could function as an early
warning system
if it finds the virus in one sewer but
not in another
that could help public health
authorities focus attention and
resources on areas where trouble is
brewing
even if the people there who are
shedding the virus have no symptoms and
have not been tested
you could use the data to estimate the
infection rate in the catchment area
around the sewage treatment plant
that could help you decide if you need
to do more or less testing
or whether or not to relax restrictions
based on the readings you're getting
from the water
it's not clear why authorities in
germany won't embrace this early warning
system
the method was developed in cooperation
with the frankfurt sanitation department
but the city hasn't started to use it we
asked the health department why that is
in a written response it expressed
doubts about its practicability
at the university of bonn we talked to
martin exner
a professor of public health who
approves of the new method and thinks it
should be used
this is how he interprets the
authority's reticence to deploy it
it is often it appears they're abiding
by rigid principles
and are finding it hard to embrace new
ideas such as wastewater monitoring
i think we need to both demand more
courage and offer more encouragement
in this area
germany's association of towns and
municipalities has also weighed in on
the issue
anything that helps us combat the
pandemic should be made available
that includes monitoring waste water
but for now this potentially valuable
system developed in germany is not being
used in germany
critics say that's down to an abundance
of bureaucracy and a lack of courage
and warn that in the worst case such
inertia could cost
lives and you would have seen susanna
luckner in that report she's a professor
for wastewater engineering and joins us
today thanks for joining us and being on
the show
why do you think germany hasn't embraced
this early warning system of yours
well thanks for having me and um well i
think it's it's a
it's a federal issue in germany we have
the the organization in the
in the states and the system that we
have between the
wastewater sector and the public health
sector is not it's not prepared for
for what we are facing and there's it's
basically a lack of communication i
would say
some authorities argue that this system
isn't practical
do you agree uh no
i mean we we are ready um we have the
methodologies ready we
we can we can start the analysis
anytime i think we have to be aware of
the limitations but
the it's definitely out of the
experimental stage
okay to understand this let me pose the
question differently why have the
netherlands
and spain and the united states embrace
this system
i mean for the netherlands as far as i
understand i mean they they have first
of all done this already
um years ago with with the polio virus
and there's a
much better connection between the
public health sector and the water
sector already
and they seem to have a better
management of or
also see more more potential in this in
this type of information and i think
that's why they are
ahead of us maybe to add on that i hope
that in germany we will
uh improve because also the european
union just posted
uh recommendations to include
wastewater-based epidemiology and
wastewater-based monitoring and will
support the member states so i i'm
still optimistic that we can also move
along with this in germany
well susana could you explain to us how
it actually works your system
um what we do is usually we take samples
from it or we get samples from a
vegetable treatment plant over
over 24 hours they are collected we
bring it to the lab we we do some
some preparation and and extraction and
then we basically go ahead with a
similar analysis
or tools that are used in the in the
medical sector
one is the the quantitative pcr and the
other is the sequencing and we get
different types of information from from
this analysis
and the information you get you've said
is less biased than official figures
could you explain
that to viewers yes i mean what what we
get is basically an unbiased picture
of what's happening happening in the
catchment of that treatment plan because
people may not want to get tested or may
not feel sick but they'll all go to the
toilet so um that's why we get
in that sense a better picture of what's
going on
and um even though it's it's basically a
pool sample that that we have
we can still monitor um loads of the
virus coming in or even now
the mutations that are in a certain
catchment and
can the data also be used to estimate
the the actual number of infected people
from what we've done i would be hesitant
to do that i know colleagues have tried
that but
in that sense i i would say we don't
know enough from the
from the medical aside how many
uh or how much virus one person actually
excretes and
i would i wouldn't do that but i'm a
wastewater engineer so maybe the medical
people
are more capable of doing that
at the end of the day couldn't this also
be used to
trace other diseases other infections
definitely i mean i i think everything
that is
somewhat um in the water and can be
spread by
by water um or through through the
wastewater can be detected and i mean we
are also working on anti-microbial
resistances and
that is a big issue and it will will
remain a big issue and i think we can
also use
everything that's now done and all the
concepts that are made
for tracking resistance genes or even
other pathogens
bacteria viruses um everything that is
that is
that goes through water let's hope that
uh the germans can overcome their
bureaucratic problems and
and take this on it would be nice to see
susanna lucknow great to have you on the
show today
thank you well from one star scientist
to my favorite scientist and
correspondent derek williams
with the questions you guys have been
leaving on our youtube channel
please explain the difference between a
new strain and a new variant
this is tough to do since even
virologists
seem to view the differences as fairly
fluid but
but let's start by maybe going over some
of the other
biology basics that you've you've
probably
learned this year already first is that
although
it's technically not considered alive
a virus evolves constantly as it
replicates just like living things do
its genetic code changes because
mistakes happen
as the code is copied by a living
cell that gives rise to what are
commonly known
as mutants now for complicated
biological reasons
not every mutation leads to actual
physical changes in a viruses structure
but but when it does you can begin
thinking of that mutant
as a variant now a variant
is generally considered a strain when
it's
wandered even farther down that road and
acquired
characteristics and and behaviors based
on its new structure
that clearly distinguish it from other
earlier forms so you could say that
although all strains are variants
not all variants are strains let's maybe
make
a comparison from the macro world um
we've been
genetically engineering dogs for
thousands of years
through selective breeding and it's
pretty astounding how
how different they can look but dogs all
share
common characteristics that allow you to
instantly identify
an animal as a dog whether it's a
chihuahua
or a newfoundland the different breeds
can be viewed
as variants on the canine genome
but go far enough back and and split off
another evolutionary branch
and you end up with the modern wolf
which
has a common ancestor but some distinct
characteristics and behaviors that allow
us
to instantly identify it as a wolf
so if they were viruses then breeds of
dogs
would be variants while dogs and wolves
would be strains now i'm the first to
admit that the analogy
is imperfect but maybe it makes the
terms
a little easier to grasp
so mutants variants strains
thank you derek and in more dog news the
pandemic has led to a boom in
pet ownership but that's also seen a
rise in animal trafficking
german police save these little cuties
suffering from diarrhea and exhaustion
they were passing from hungary through a
german motorway check on their way to
belgium
there were 101 pups it's believed their
papers were fake
the illegal trade is booming in europe
so be careful what you buy
activists say eight million puppies are
trafficked every year
it can have a huge impact on the health
and welfare of the animals
tax evasion is also an issue
thank you for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]
you